I got my start in animation quite
accidentally I did not go into animation
intentionally it just I went to art
school and I was going to study painting
and drawing and for some strange reason
that first year there was a compulsory
animation course which everyone had to
take as part of their core curriculum
and so I fought it all the way I was not
interested in animation at all it never
occurred to me to be involved in
animation and I was shown a lot of
National Film Board films and i
definitely fell in love with the medium
and stayed with it because i had made
films in school i also got a chance of
direct films of the National Film Award
right away so I made a few short films
and then I proposed the the tender
Taylor Cinderella penguin good people
were always portrayed as beautiful and
evil people were always portrayed as
ugly and I wanted to sort of even the
field and I thought a good way to do
that would be to make them all penguins
this is the story of Cinderella told
with penguins I wanted to tell the story
without words so I cut together a music
track I went into the NFB national film
board stock library and took stock music
and films that were used in other films
music that was used in other films and I
cut that all together first and from
there i storyboarded the the film and
animated and choreographed it to this
music soundtrack the whole film was
drawn directly on sale there was no
paper there were no paper drawings
strong on cell with a crow quill pen and
India ink and no line test it was the
way I worked it's strange way and since
then I don't work on sale at all I've
been happy to kiss it goodbye and i've
been working in digital for many years
we both went into filmmaking Wendy
documentary and I wasn't quite sure
which direction I was going in and we we
had an animation instructor a guy named
Hugh folds who just by being in a film
department you were peripheral e
involved with animation and
he he showed great films and some of
those being the films of Caroline leaf
and Janet Perlman also urine or Stein
and the other Great Eastern European
filmmakers and I think it hit both Wendy
and me that this was a world you could
have entirely to yourself so I had been
out on innumerable film shoots in rain
in my slicker and they give you can
chili for lunch and you'd have zillions
of people you'd have to organize need
shoot a minute of film and I just
thought I just want to do it all myself
and the process was extremely nonlinear
experimental I think it's only in
retrospect that I realized it's it's an
extension of a preoccupation I had with
cities which and I've always been struck
by the intimacy with which we live in
cities were very close to each other
with of you cheek by jowl and apartments
next door to people but we're all
strangers for the most part but in when
the day breaks would expand it into
thinking about the city as a as an
organism and that there are pipes and
wires that run through cities which are
like vessels carrying blood and
electrical impulse as that kind of thing
cities without the people in it are
really just an infrastructure and you
know without people turning on the water
which is kind of the lifeblood which
kind of connects us and that you know
the the water i turn on in my house is
coming from the same place as the house
down the street it's it's connective
tissue but it is really the people who
live in it kind of like the soul of a
city's like the soul of an organism that
really is what's important
you